hey guys how's it going I was racking my
brain trying to come up with a special
way to make this video sir say how I
really feel and it was it was really
hard this time because I usually take
the old vlogs that I've done in the past
and I throw them into premiere and I
start cutting them up and watching
through them but this time I took every
single vlog I've ever done along with
some other videos that I've done with
other people and I and I threw him into
premiere and I'll actually show you it
right now and it's um it was really hard
for me this time and I've actually tried
to make this video that you're seeing
right now multiple times because I look
back at the things that I've done and
how long I've been doing this and in the
grand scheme of my life it's not that
long I've been on YouTube less than
three years but I see these videos and
it astonishes me that my entire career
on YouTube can be compressed into just a
few videos that you guys can see a
little montage of my life and as I grow
older but what's even more amazing is
that when I see these videos and I see
myself in the past I remember everything
about it I remember every moment I
remember exactly what I was trying to
say or what a point I was trying to make
even if the words weren't coming across
correctly and I remember like starting
out and thinking that ooh this would be
a cool hobby and then it quickly turned
into oh my gosh I have a huge
responsibility to so many people like
back when I started I thought you know
50,000 subscribers was the most amazing
thing in the world and I couldn't even
fathom that that many people wanted to
watch my videos or had a reason to spend
their lives watching the drivel that I
was putting out on YouTube but you know
it's it's still there you know it's
still there and every moment of my life
is still there on that screen and it's
put out in front of you guys and it's
put out for everyone to see and it'll
probably stay there like long after I'm
gone my videos will somehow still be
here on the Internet
and people will see it and they won't
even know like me at all and they'll see
these things that I've left here and
it's just a weird feeling to know that
I've been trying to say thank you for so
long I've been trying to show you guys
for so long that I had so much fun doing
these things with these people who gave
me these opportunities to do great
things and like when I moved to LA all
the sudden I was able to have more and
more opportunities with great people and
like I'm I miss the simplicity of it you
know it got really complicated really
quickly and I'm not saying that's a bad
thing but it's it I sometimes need to
take a moment to remember that I mean I
miss I miss the simple pleasures of you
know just knowing that I make video and
it's it's just there to be done and then
but what I'm trying to say is it I'm so
grateful for how far things have come
and I'm so grateful for the things that
I've been able to do and I'm so grateful
for everything that I've been able to
accomplish in my endeavor to be a better
person in my endeavor to see the things
that people have done for me and and how
people have been eager to meet me and
people have been so eager to like tell
me how great I am when in reality I'm
just a guy from Ohio that likes to make
videos and you know I kind of had a
knack for it and then people caught on
but you know it still amazes me every
day that so many people are willing to
dedicate their time to me and the cool
things that I've been able to do and
I've been able to have so much fun with
it and we've been able to do so much
good with it and I know I'm getting off
topic and I'm rambling and I was
actually supposed to talk about the
videos that you're seeing right now but
it's just it's it's a strange time warp
to go forward in time and see the things
that have been able to do but what I'm
really trying to say is it I am so
thankful for you guys giving me the
opportunity to come out here and meet
these cool people and work with it but I
always want to be able to look back at
the things that I've done and and
remember how far I've come and and
remember the milestones that I've
crossed and remember the things that
I've learned on the way and the people
that I've met and just people that I may
have you know lost it at one point or
another because like the strangest thing
is
I've gotten letters and emails emails
mostly no I don't get letters anymore
but I've gotten emails from people who
are telling me about fans were like at
the start of my channel there are some
fans that watched me in the very
beginning that then aren't here anymore
and you know it's like they tell me that
I was able to bring joy into their life
and I was able to show them like a
little bit happiness and they're gone
now there's so many people here that
like this only people that the videos
have touched that some of them aren't
here anymore and this and then that's I
don't even have words to describe what
that is or what that means right now but
it just emphasizes how much I need to
try you know everyday to make not only
my videos better to be ensure that we as
a community do more for each other oh
I'm sorry I'm really having trouble
saying words right now oh sorry
this is just really hard to video to get
through because various reasons that
I've said and I don't mean to turn into
a blubbering fool that's not what I
wanted to do I wanted to try to actually
say some words but yeah it's just
whenever we hit these milestones I
always think back to like where we've
come from and where I've come from and
you know a lot of time I ages you know I
wish my dad could see how what I've done
and I wish yeah some things that I would
have done differently but I'm just
really happy right now I mean may not
seem like it it may not seem like I'm
I'm not that happy but you know I'm
happier than I've ever been because I
have a purpose and I have like a way to
go and I've been thrust into the
leadership position of five million
people and I could very easily just sit
back and keep making you know the silly
videos without actually connecting with
you guys and without actually telling
you guys what means to me and what it
means to me is that I'm so happy to
dedicate my life to entertain you guys
and not only that but leading you guys
to try to inspire the world around you
and you've done it in droves and we've
done it over and over here and I'm a
mess right now but so I'll wrap this up
quickly just thank you guys so much for
believing in me and understanding that
um I'm not just a face on the Internet
I'm a real person and I'm a real person
that wants to connect with five million
people even though that's literally
impossible but through the magic of the
Internet it is so just thank you guys so
much for five million subscribers and I
know we're gonna hit another milestone
down the road and I know I'm going to
turn into a blubbering fool again
because it gets worse every time because
there's more look back on there's more
things to remember and there's more
times in my life to be proud of
so just thank you guys so much for
everything that you've done for me
continue to be a great inspiration for
the community in the world and everyone
else and you guys are truly just kind of
the best fans in the world and I mean
that so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna keep making videos on
YouTube for as long as I'm able which is
hopefully a long time so thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye